JANUARY EIGHTEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT.
AND I'M WELCOME OUR NEW MEMBERS
TO THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
WHEN HE CREATE.
IN A DREAM IS AREA MISTER
MYSTERIOUS UNFORTUNATELY WILL BE
ABSENT TODAY BUT HE WILL BE
ITEM.
AND HE REPLACED JUST FOR TODAY
BY MISTER JONES SAWYER.
NOTING. THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
I'M WILL GO AHEAD AND START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WE WILL START
WITH MISTER TEAM.
A B. EIGHTY SEVEN ONCE WE GET A
QUORUM HERE THIS WILL ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
YOU MAY START.
BUT HE'S TESTING DRIVERLESS
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES TO PROVIDE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES. WITH WRITTEN
NOTICE AND A LAW AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITH A LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION PLAN.
THESE ARE TO REGULATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN.
VETTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES UNFORTUNATELY THE
REGULATORY PROCESS HAS TAKEN
OVER TWO AND A HALF YEARS AND
DOESN'T REALLY. HAPPEN AND
INSIGHT.
WE HAVE WE FACE THE POSSIBLY
THAT THESE VEHICLES VERY SOON
COULD BE ON THE ROAD TO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE. THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS THE ABILITY TO
POLICE OUR ROADS AND TWO I KNOW
HOW TO DEAL WITH THESE VEHICLES
IF SOMETHING SHOULD COME UP.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EUROPE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HE NODDED WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AYE CHRIS
LEAVE DEPARTMENT FINANCED THE
FILE.
STARTING OFF DEAD.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SCENE AND YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE.
I DISRESPECT LAST REBEL.
I AM OKAY AS SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
THAT BALLOT THANK YOU MISTER
TEAM THANK YOU.
JUST WANT TO REMIND FOLKS I'M
BOTH COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
PEOPLE PRESENT TEAM THAT WE HAVE
AND WE GO FROM A REGULAR MEETING
TO OUR SUSPENSE FILES SO WOULD
BE GREAT AND A LOT OF YOU WANNA
GET HOME. IF WE COULD GET A
QUORUM HERE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
AND WE CAN GET THE PRESENTING
AUTHORS TO ALSO. MAKE IT WE'RE
WAITING FOR MR MCCARTY.
AND MISTER ALLEN I SEE YOU HERE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT.
YOU'LL BE PRESENT AND AB TEN
FIFTY TWO.
IF YOU'LL WAIT JUST A MINUTE
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL
ROLE SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM THANK YOU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROKE.
CALDERONE.
CREEL.
CHAO.
EGGMAN.
LONG. FRIEDMAN HERE GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER AIR.
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK THEIR BREATH.
I AM WHAT WE HAVE A QUORUM MORE
STILL MISSING IN.
.
AND IF DEMOCRATS W. ROLL CALL SO
AND WITH THAT MR ALLEN YOU MAY
PROCEED ON AB EIGHTY SEVEN NO
I'M SORRY.
AB TEN FIFTY TWO.
BEFORE IS CURRENTLY THE LOWEST
RANK STATE EARNING CONSISTENT
SCORE OF THIRTY FOUR BY THE US
PUBLIC INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP.
ON CALIFORNIA'S E. BUDGET
WEBSITE IT IS NOT AS TRANSPARENT
AS AND IS ACCESSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC AS IT COULD AND SHOULD
BE.
THE WEBSITE PROVIDES AN
UNFRIENDLY USER INTERFACE WHICH
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE AND
CONTAINS NO GRASS OR SPREADSHEET
FORMATS.
THE BUDGET WEBSITE IS ALSO
MISSING IN A RAINY DAY
INFORMATION REGARDING HOW MUCH
MONEY STATE RECEIVES FROM TAX
REVENUE ETCETERA.
CALIFORNIANS.
WHAT?
VERY MUCH CALIFORNIA'S WOULD
LOVE TO KNOW HOW MUCH THEIR
GOVERNMENTS IS SPENDING AND
WHERE IT IS SPENDING IT IN
EASILY ACCESSIBLE FORMAT.
CALIFORNIA'S OVERWHELMINGLY
PASSED PROPOSITION FIFTY FOUR
WITH HOPE PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNMENT AND TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC.
HOME TO SILICON VALLEY OF COURSE
OUR STUDENTS CONSIDER TO BE THE
BEACON OF INNOVATION AND THE
MODERNIZATION OF CONNECTING
PEOPLE INFORMATION IN OUR MODERN
ERA. SO IT'S ONLY FITTING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WEBSITES NEAR THE
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES THAT ARE
BEING PIONEERED IN OUR STATE.
IN MARCH OF TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE
THE U. S. PUBLICAN INTEREST
RESEARCH GROUP RELEASED THEIR
ANNUAL FOLLOWING THE MONEY IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND OHIO EARNED
THE NUMBER ONE TRANSPARENCY
RANKING IN THE COUNTRY FOR
PROVIDING ONLINE ACCESS TO
GOVERNMENT SPENDING DATA. OHIO'S
ALSO PROBABLY FEATURED IN THE
REPORT AFTER CLIMBING FROM FORTY
SIX TO FIRST IN SPENDING
TRANSPARENCY AS RESULT OF
TREASURE JOSH MANDEL'S RELEASE
OF OHIO CHECKBOOK DOT COM.
CALIFORNIA AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED IS CURRENTLY THE
LOWEST RANK STATE ONLINE
TRANSPARENCY.
IN AB TEN FIFTY TWO WOULD SIMPLY
MODIFY ARE FISCAL SYSTEMS
TRANSPARENCY COMPONENT TO
ACQUIRE THIS IS TO BE MORE
INTERACTIVE SEARCHABLE AND
REGULARLY UPDATED. MUCH LIKE
OHIO'S IS.
LAST WEEK GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
UNVEILED TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
PLAN I'D CALLED FOR A HUNDRED
NINETY POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SPENDING.
WHICH SECTION OVER A FIFTY
PERCENT INCREASE IN GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE SENSHI SINCE HE
GAINED OFFICE IN TWENTY TEN.
IN ADDITION A TWENTY SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVED
ADDITIONAL TEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW TAXES AND LAST YEAR AS WE
ALL WELL KNOW.
THIS BODY ARE ALL THOSE A SLIM
MARGIN BARELY PASSED THE FIFTY
TWO BILLION DOLLAR.
NEW GAS AND CAR REGISTRATION
TAX
SO IT'S ONLY FAIR THAT WE MOVE
IN A MORE TRANSPARENT. DIRECTION
TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSTAND
HOW ALL OF THIS YOU KNOW EXTRA
REVENUE EXTRA TAX FUNDS ARE
BEING EXPENDABLE SPENT. AND
ALLOW THEM TO SEE A BREAKDOWN
ONLINE EASILY SEARCHABLE AND
EASILY ACCESSIBLE.
THIS BILL IS A PRODUCT OF THE
HARD WORK OF THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
COMMITTEE WHERE I TOOK ALL OF
THEIR AMENDMENTS IN THIS BILL
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL IS ALL
SAID OUT OF.
VERY MINOR INEXORABLE COSTS BUT
WOULD PROVIDE A HUGE RETURN TO
TAXPAYERS. YOU THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
HAS THE POWER OF THE PURSE
STRINGS IN THE ABILITY TO SPEND
CALIFORNIANS MONEY. IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE THAT OUR WEBSITE
ACCURATELY REFLECTS WHERE THAT
MONEY IS BEING SPENT IN EASILY
ACCESSIBLE AND SOCIAL FORMAT FOR
THE BENEFIT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
OTHERS BILLS ENTIRELY BIPARTISAN
THAT WE CAN ALL MEMBERS TO DATE
OTHERS EXTREMELY MINOR COSTS AND
THERE'S A MASSIVE RETURN
TAXPAYERS WITH THE STATE OF OHIO
TO THIS AS I MENTIONED THEY WENT
FROM FORTY SIX AND TRANSPARENCY
NATION. TO NUMBER ONE AND I
THINK THAT EVERYBODY HERE IS
VERY PROUD OF MANY OF THE THINGS
ARE IN THE BUDGET MAIN MANY OF
US HERE PROBABLY LIKE AND. THAT
TO CHANGE SOME ITEMS IN THE
BUDGET. IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE
GIVE CALIFORNIANS THE ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW OUR BUDGET WORKS
AND WHERE THEIR TAX DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT WITH THAT AYE AYE
URGING AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I WE ESTIMATE MINOR AND ABSORB
WILL COST FOR MULTIPLE STATE
ENTITY.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER BIGELOW AND ASSEMBLY AND
BY MR FUNG AND THE CHAIR HAS
RECOMMENDED A NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL BECAUSE. AS CALLOUS ALREADY
IN THE PROCESS OF DOING THIS SO
WE THINK THE BILL IS A NECESSARY
THIS TIME DESPITE THE LOW COST.
WITHOUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER ALLEN AYE YEAH YOU KNOW I
I SIT ON THE NUMBER OF THE
COMMITTEES AND WE DO SEE YOU
KNOW A BUNCH VERY AGENCIES
TRYING TO TO MODERNIZE IT AND
YOU KNOW.
MAKE THEMSELVES BETTER AND AND
MORE STREAMLINED I CAN TELL YOU
THAT UNFORTUNATELY I
IMPLEMENTATION IS NOT EXACTLY
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE YOU COULD
ASK ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU
WE'VE HAD WE'VE GOT AROUND
AROUND ABOUT THESE THINGS AND HE
IS OF A OF AN EQUAL MIND. THAT
YOU KNOW WE REALLY DO NEED OUR
OUR WEBSITES YOU MORE
TRANSPARENT MORE SEARCHABLE
EASIER FOR CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS
BUT THAT'S TALKING GENERAL IT
LET'S JUST TALK SPECIFICALLY
THIS IS ABOUT CALIFORNIANS
MONEY.
CALIFORNIANS REALLY YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO SEE WHETHER MONEY SPENT
EVERY SINGLE LINE ITEM NOW OHIO
DID THIS AND NOW THEY'RE NUMBER
ONE IN THE NATION FOR
TRANSPARENCY. IF EVERYONE HERE
IS PROUD OF THE VOTES THEY'VE
CAST WITH THE BUDGET LOOKS LIKE.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SHOW THAT
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF
YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS OF WHAT'S
IN THE BUDGET YOU SHOULD ALSO
WILL SHOW THAT TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE EASIEST FOR A
POSSIBLE. I UNDERSTAND HIS
CALLOUS UNDERTAKEN SOME EFFORTS
TO TO MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION
THIS BILL WILL SIMPLY INSURE
THAT THEY THEY FINISH THOSE
EFFORTS AND THE LEGISLATURE
MAKES ITS INTENT VERY CLEAR.
THAT AS THERE ARE EXTREMELY
MINOR INEXORABLE COSTS HERE AND
SUCH A MASS RETURN TO TAXPAYERS
THAT TRANSPARENCY IS OUR GOAL
THE LEGISLATURE WITH OUR BUDGET.
THANK YOU MISTER ALLEN I'LL ALL
AND AGAIN STATE WE HAVE MINOR IN
ITS OVERALL COSTS BECAUSE THIS
IS CURRENTLY UNDER WAY SO THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING THE SPELL.
UNFORTUNATELY IT DIES WITH THE
C. ROLL CALL WITH I'M
REPUBLICANS VOTING YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY.
YOU'LL BE PRESENT IN A AB ELEVEN
AND ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION BY MISS RESTS.
A SECOND BY MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU THIS IS A BILL THAT
SOMEONE MEMBER BONFIRE JOINT
AUTHORS THAT WE KNOW THAT.
INCREASE
SCREENINGS WILL HELP.
TO OTHERS ESPECIALLY WITH THAT
BRING DEVELOPMENTS IN THE FIRST
THREE YEARS OF LIFE THAT
ESSENTIAL FOR LIFELONG LEARNING
BE AND BEHAVIOR AND HEALTH AND
UNDERSTANDING THE CHALLENGES AND
GETTING THEM. PROPER HEALTH AND
EDUCATION SERVICES EARLY AGE IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND TAKE
YOU FOR YOUR.
RECOMMENDATION ASK YOU RIGHT
VOTE.
THINK YOU'RE THERE'S WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING.
CHORE GONZALEZ MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DOCTOR
NANCY HIROTA AND I AM THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES AT THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE. AB ONE ELEVEN ELEVEN.
I AM DEEPLY CONNECTED TO THIS
WORK EVOLVING AROUND
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS HERE
CALIFORNIA AND PARTICULARLY HERE
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
SIMPLY PUT CALIFORNIA IS UNDER
PERFORMING WHEN IT COMES TO
IDENTIFYING DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS
IN OUR YOUNG CHILDREN.
UNIDENTIFIED DELAYS CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT A CHILD'S
SCHOOL READINESS HAVE LONG TERM
EFFECTS ON THEIR OVERALL WELL
BEING AND INCREASE SPECIAL
EDUCATION BECAUSE.
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS ARE THE
BEST WAY TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
DELAYS AND IS THE FIRST STEP TO
ENSURING CHILDREN ARE CONNECTED
TO APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
AB ELEVEN IS NEEDED TO CLARIFY
STANDARDS FOR WHEN DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS ARE TO TAKE PLACE AND
REQUIRES THE USE OF A VALIDATED
SCREENING TOOL.
AT NO ADDITIONAL COST TO THE
STATE THE CLARIFICATIONS IN AB
ELEVEN WILL ENSURE MORE CHILDREN
ARE SCREEN FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS VERY A PORTENT TOPIC AND TO
SIMPLY MEMBER. MCCARTY FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ACTIVELY WAS
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS OF THE SPELL I
AM PLEASED TO. BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS ON THE BILL
THINKING.
OKAY TELEHEALTH ACCESS IN
SUPPORT.
WHAT IF NOT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION?
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OF FINANCES NEUTRON THIS
BILL AND ESTIMATES NO FISCAL.
IF A MOTION AND A SECOND I WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU TAKE IT OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU.
IF WE CAN GO BACK I NEED A
MOTION ON AB EIGHTY SEVEN MISTER
TEAMS BILL.
THAT'S ADAM BY MR COCHRAN SECOND
BY MISS RAYOS AND THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL.
ALRIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
CONSECUTIVE.
AT A MOTION BY MISTER CALLED
AROUND US AND BY MYSTERIOUS AND.
IF YOU COULD READ THE CONSENT
COUNTER PLEASE.
AB FOR SEVENTY NINE SIX SIXTY
FOUR EIGHT OR NINE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT. TEN THIRTEEN TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE.
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE FIFTEEN NINETY
SIX AND SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE.
GREAT.
THAT PUTS OUT ME ROLL CALL THINK
ILL OF.
AT THIS TIME WE ARE NOT GOING
TO READ OUT THE REST OF AND. THE
ITEMS THAT WERE ON THE FILE
BECAUSE THEY AUTOMATICALLY GO TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE AND WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO DISPENSING OF
THE SUSPENSE FILE.
I DO WANT TO KNOW.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND SOME THE
JANUARY SUSPENSE FILE WHICH IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT AND I DO
WANT TO KNOW THIS BECAUSE AS WE
GO THROUGH YOU'LL HEAR SOME
CLARIFICATIONS. WE WERE REALLY
UP AGAINST THE CLOCK RIGHT NOW
AND BECAUSE THE ASSEMBLY PRIDES
ITSELF ON ONLY PUTTING OUT BILLS
THAT ARE FULLY FORMED IN NOT
SENDING OVER THINGS TO THE
SENATE.
THAT THAT STILL NEED SOME
REVEAL THEIR NUMBER OF BILLS
ALTHOUGH GOOD IN.
IN THEORY AND GOOD AND POLICY
CAMP AT THIS TIME BE LET OUT UP
OFF.
SUSPENSE BECAUSE THEY REALLY
SHOULD BE REINTRODUCED AND.
SET THROUGH THE PROCESS ONE
MORE TIME EITHER AS THEY ARE NOW
OR FOR CHANGES THAT WE'VE I'M
HOPEFULLY SPOKEN TO THE AUTHORS
ABOUT WILL NOTE THAT AS WE GO
THROUGH AND AND FOR THAT I
APOLOGIZE FOR HOLDING SOME
OTHERWISE GOOD BILLS.
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE.
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING MISTER
BIGELOW.
WE'RE PASSING OUT.
SPENCE FILE NOW.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START WITH AB
FIVE GONZALEZ FLETCHER THE
OPPORTUNITY WORK ACT WE'RE GONNA
HOLD ON COMMITTEE AB NINE AND
GARCIA SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR
TAMPONS WHEN HOLD OUT COMMITTEE.
AB SIXTEEN BY MISTER COOPER I
HAVE A MOTION BY A.
MR CALDERONE IN A SECOND BY
MISTER.
JONES SAWYER. ITEM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WELL WHEN WE
GET THE SURFARIS RIGHT.
SORRY WERE A LITTLE RUSTY.
.
AB SIXTEEN COOPER AND THAT
EXPANDS DNA COLLECTION FOR
MISDEMEANORS THIS PAST SAYS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE BILL TO
VIOLENT MISDEMEANORS.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION SECOND FOR
ALL DO PASS OR DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS FOR THE REST OF
SUSPENSE FILE.
AB FORTY THREE THEREMIN TAX ON
PRISON CONTRACTS.
THIS IS A UNIQUE BILL THAT THE
pINTENDED CREATE MORE COST TO
THE
STATEMENT UNINTENTIONALLY DOES
JUST THAT BY TAXING VENDORS
INSTEAD OF JUST PRIVATE PRISON
PROFITS WE ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR
TO RE INTRODUCE THIS BILL. AND
THAT LIMITS THE SCOPE OF THE
STATE LIABILITY AND WITHOUT
WE'RE GONNA HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWO SEVENTY TO GIPSON SAILOR
CITY WATER UTILITIES WITHOUT
VOTER APPROVAL HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB THREE TEN MEDINA REPORTING
PART TIME FACULTY OFFICE HOURS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THREE NINETY THREE QUIRK
SILVA TUITION FREEZE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB FOR TWENTY SEVEN
MAR SUCI CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB FIVE FIFTY REYES LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
PROCREATION INCREASE THE BASE
ALLOCATION OF FISCAL YEARS WHEN
FUNDING IS PROVIDED. THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FIVE NINETY FIVE WOULD STATE
OVERSIGHT OF HEALTH CARE PLAN
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO RECAST AND FURTHER
SPECIFY THE DETAILS OF THE
REVEAL. THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
AB SIX APART MULLIN FIRST BIRTH
TO FIRST GRADE LICENSE OPTION
FOR DAYCARE CENTERS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL.
AB SIX TWENTY SIX GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS FOR SALES OF HOME
COOKED FOOD DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ADD LANGUAGE DEFINING THIRD
PARTIES AND LIMIT THEIR
LIABILITY. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
AB SEVEN FORTY NINE IRWIN REAL
ESTATE HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
SEVEN SIXTY ONE MULLIN HISTORY
AND SOCIAL SCIENCE PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN QUIRK SILVA
MASTER SMALL BUSINESS LICENSE
CENTER WITH GOMEZ DO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL.
ABC EIGHT SIXTY TWO MAIENSCHEIN
PAPER SUCCESS GRANT PROGRAM TO
PASS ON AND A ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE LIBYAN
CRIMINAL RE SENTENCING PREVENT
TRENDS TO PASS ON IN A ROLL
CALL.
AB NINE HUNDRED GONZALEZ
FLETCHER VICTIM COMPENSATION FOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO SPECIFY
COMPENSATION IS BASED. IN
CALCULATED ON MINIMUM WAGE AND
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. IN I'M SORRY AB NINE NINE
NINE STEINORTH STUDY OF TRAUMA
KITS HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB NINE
SIXTY TWO ALAN TRAVIS ALAN STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING FOR
SEAPORTS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB NINE EIGHTY SIX GALLAGHER
TWELVE MY FISHING LICENSES IN
VETERAN DISCOUNTS FOR HUNTING
AND FISHING LICENSES.
DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
PROVIDE THE TWELVE MONTH FISHING
LICENSE AT A HUNDRED THIRTY
PERCENT OF THE COST OF THE
ANNUAL LICENSE. ALLOW THAT PART
ED DF.
W. COMMISSION TO JUST THE PRICE
OF THE LICENSE TO FULLY RECOVER
ADMINISTRATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS AND SUNSET
THE TWELVE MONTH LICENSE AFTER
THREE YEARS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
AB NINE NINETY ONE RARE AS
FOSTER YOUTH INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN THE MON CAL
GRANT BE SERVICE INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL.AB TEN NINETY SEVEN LEVINE
NO SMOKING AND STATE PARKS AND
BEACHES DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE WEBER CSU
SUPPORT STAFF MERIT SALARY
INCREASES PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
AB TWELVE SIXTY TO EDUARDO
GARCIA GANG CRIME AND VIOLENCE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM DO PASS ON
AN A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE CHU
LITTORINA WILL PLAN TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE CALTRANS
TO PRIVATIZE REMOVE THE LID ON
HIGHWAYS WITH THE HIGHEST
TRAFFIC VOLUMES IN INCIDENCES OF
LETTER. AND AMEND THE STUDY TO
REQUIRE SPECIFIC INFORMATION
REQUIRED CALTRANS TO REPORT THE
PIE NEEDS TO LEGISLATURE TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FOURTEEN NINETEEN QUIRK CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR PESTICIDES USED
VIOLATIONS DO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL.
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN LOW PROPERTY
LOSS SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS TO
PASS ON EIGHTY A ROLL CALL.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN QUIRK
SILVA SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
PROGRAM TO PASS ON IN A ROLL
CALL.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO QUIRK SILVA
LATE PAYMENT PENALTIES DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF STATE CERTIFIED
SMALL BUSINESS REVISED
LEGISLATIVE INTENT AND MAKE
VARIOUS OTHER TECHNICAL AND
CONFORMING CHAIR CHANGES TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX LEVINE
HEALTH AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT
STANDARDS THE MODELING INDUSTRY.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS IT'S
AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION UNFORTUNATELY WAS
JUST INTRODUCE AND STILL HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO WE HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THAT THE AUTHOR
REINTRODUCE THIS LEGISLATION.
AND FOR LONGER PAID OF REVIEW IN
THE POLICY COMMITTEE HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE CHRISTINA
GARCIA LEAD ACID BATTERIES TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO CHANGE
THE NAME OF THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION TO THE CALTRAIN
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. AND REVISE THE
DEFINITION OF A PERSON ENGAGED
IN BUSINESS IN THE STATE WITH
THE RESPECT OF.
BATTERY MANUFACTURING EXEMPT
BATTERY SOLD USED CARS FROM THE
P. AT A REGISTRATION EXEMPTION
FROM MANUFACTURERS WITH
AGREEMENTS WITH BATTERY
IMPORTERS AT REPORTING
REQUIREMENT PROVIDE OTHER
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT GETS
OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS
ABSTAIN.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE BURKE
INSURANCE REGULATION OF AUTO
BODY LABOR RATES SINCE DURING.
THE WHAT OTHER HAS WORKED VERY
HARD TO BRING STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
FEEL LIKE THAT BILL IS ALMOST
THERE HOWEVER WE WOULD HAVE TO
PASS THIS BILL OUT INCOMPLETE.
WE ASK THAT THE AUTHOR
REINTRODUCES SPELLING GO THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE PROCESS TO BRING
IT BACK HERE POOR AND ME TO
SPEND XIN. THAT IT WAS HELD IN
COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTEEN FIFTEEN
QUIRK SILVA PROCESS TO SOLICIT
DONATIONS FOR A NATIONAL TRADE
INVESTMENT OFFICE TO PASS WITHIN
A ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTEEN QUIRK SILVA
CALTRAIN COMPETES TAX CREDIT
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
WE'RE GONNA DO THE RARE.
OCCURRENCE OF DOING AN SP BILL I
WOULD BE CLEAR THAT THE ONLY
REASON WE'RE DOING THIS IS TO
PREPARE FOR A JUNE BALLOT
OTHERWISE I'M WE WOULD NOT BE
TAKING UP. ANY S. B. AT THIS
TIME. S. B. FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
GLAZER PROPERTY TAX EXCLUSION
FOR RAINWATER CAPTURE SYSTEMS DO
PASS.
S. C. ON A ROLL CALL AS SEE
EIGHT NINE GLAZIER A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT FOR
PROPERTY TAX EXCLUSION FOR
RAINWATER CAPTURE YOU PASS ON AN
EVIL COLOR.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
TODAY COMMITTEE ADJOURNMENT